i
[Música]
una docena de senadores republicanos
anunciaron que no reconocerán la
victoria de joe biden como presidenta de
eeuu existiendo en acusaciones
infundadas de fraude electoral 11 ellos
exigen una auditoría de los resultados
en los estados pendulares donde donald
kohn perdió hoy se posiciona el nuevo
congreso y la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes nancy pelosi busca la
reelección
se cumple un año del asesinato del
general iraní qasem soleimani muerto en
un ataque con un drone estadounidense se
registra en protesta frente a la
embajada de eeuu en irak y actos de
conmemoración elián en el aniversario se
vive en medio de fuertes tensiones entre
la república islámica y la unión
americana tenemos reporte de etcétera
la autora de la autoridad reguladora de
medicamentos de la india autorizó el
domingo el uso de emergencia de una
vacuna desarrollada por la farmacéutica
local barata my own tech esto después de
haber aprobado la desarrollada por
astrazéneca y la universidad de oxford
el gobierno planea una de las campañas
de vacunación más grandes del planeta
bienvenidos sobre nueva mañana de
información de américa latina y del
mundo a quien tras 24 mi nombre es
liliana valencia iniciamos en eeuu donde
un grupo de al menos 11 senadores
republicanos anunciaron que no
reconocerán los votos electorales de
algunos estados y existiendo infundadas
acusaciones de fraude promovidas por el
presidente de donald trump los 11 se
suman así a otros senadores george coli
que ya había anunciado su intención de
rechazar la victoria de joe biden este
domingo se posiciona un nuevo congreso y
la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes nancy pelosi espera ser
reelecta veamos el informe son días
movidos en el congreso de eeuu y esa
atención se ve allá afuera del capitolio
los republicanos están muy divididos
mientras el presidente del ancho y los
demócratas en una rara coincidencia
quieren enviar cheques por dos mil
dólares a los estadounidenses para
paliar los efectos de la pandemia una
mayoría de los republicanos no quiere
que sean más de los 600 dólares ya
aprobados por ambas cámaras
mcconnell ha bloqueado una nueva
votación y pese a que los republicanos
más importantes han terminado por
reconocer la victoria de job
en las elecciones de noviembre por
primera vez en muchos años una docena de
senadores de ese partido entre los que
se encuentra el ex aspirante
presidencial del club de texas amenazan
con convertir en un show la que ha sido
siempre una votación protocolaria para
ratificar los resultados del colegio
electoral en favor del ganador
respaldando las acusaciones sin
fundamento de fraude del presidente
downtown que sigue sin reconocer su
derrota los senadores anunciaron que en
la sesión conjunta del congreso del 6 de
enero protestarán los votos electorales
de algunos estados una justa y creíble
auditoría realizada inmediatamente y
completada mucho antes del 20 de enero
mejoraría radicalmente la fe de los
estadounidenses en nuestro proceso
electoral entretanto este domingo 3 de
enero cuando se posiciona el nuevo
congreso nancy pelosi lucha por ser
reelegida presidenta de la cámara aunque
en esta ocasión tiene un margen más
apretado pues los demócratas aunque
conservan una mayoría de 222 frente a
211 de los republicanos en ese organismo
perdieron 10 escaños el 3 de noviembre
por lo visto la política en eeuu arranca
2021 tan polarizada como en 2020 y no
sólo en el congreso sino fuera de él
este fin de semana las
mcconnell kentucky y nancy pelosi en san
francisco fueron vandalizadas
se conmemora un año del asesinato del
general iraní qasem soleimani en medio
de manifestaciones en las que participan
políticos militares y ciudadanos una
vigilia se realizó en el lugar donde
murió soleimani en bagdad la capital
iraquí y se esperan otros actos
conmemorativos de veteranos informó
nuestra corresponsal catalina gómez
ángela
las imágenes que salen hoy de irán e
irak en la conmemoración del aniversario
del asesinato no solamente el general
iraní qasem soleimani sino también de
quien fuera el segundo de las llamadas
milicias hash ya xavi un frente de
movilización popular en irak abu al
mojantes no puede ser más diferente como
consecuencia del cobi 19 y las medidas
que se toman en irán donde la mayoría de
ceremonias se han llevado de manera de
manera virtual a solamente un par
presenciales con muy poca participación
y el resto de afiches y imágenes de casa
en su alemán y para recordar su imagen
en el resto de las ciudades mientras
tanto en irak han habido grandes
demostraciones la primera de ellas
anoche la vía al aeropuerto de bagdad
donde fueron asesinados el pasado 3 de
enero y esta mañana se repite lo mismo
en la gran plaza de tahrir especialmente
con milicianos que pertenecen a esas
milicias comandadas no solamente por
almirantes sino también por casen
suleimán y esto se da en un
en el que la tensión entre eeuu se irán
está en uno de sus momentos máximos
ambos países
temían un ataque contrario y eeuu había
mandado en las últimas semanas
bombarderos b-52 y también un un
submarino nuclear a la región e irán
también estaba en máxima alerta pero al
parecer todo parece tranquilo hasta el
momento como lo pudimos recordar y pero
hoy en las calles de teherán donde la
población no parece estar pensando en
esto sino más bien en la gran
contaminación que hay en la ciudad
especialmente en teherán en el día de
hoy
la india probó el uso de emergencia de
una segunda vacuna contra el coi 19
además de la inyección de oxford y
astrazéneca que ya había recibido el
visto bueno ahora se trata de un fármaco
local desarrollado por la compañía barat
ma yun tech la que recibe la luz verde
índice el segundo país que más ha
reportado casos confirmados del nuevo
coronavirus después de eeuu y se dispone
a lanzar una enorme campaña de
vacunación un verdadero reto en uno de
los países más poblados del mundo
india autorizó el uso de emergencia de
dos vacunas de astrazéneca oxford y una
de la farmacéutica local barata biotech
el gobierno indicó que la medida buscaba
acelerar el proceso de vacunación en una
población que ronda los 1.300 millones
de habitantes en medio de presiones por
el aumento de casos y el descubrimiento
de la variante de kobe 19 en su
territorio la eficacia de las vacunas
queda como el gran interrogante
astrazéneca indicó que la suya tendría
una de 70 42 por ciento de eficacia
mientras que de la india kóvacs singh no
se ha publicado ninguna cifra y se
encuentra en fase 3 de estudio desde
noviembre adaptar
luego de una examinación adecuada a esta
reguladora ha decidido aceptar las
recomendaciones del comité experto y de
acuerdo a esto las vacunas de los
laboratorios serum y barat bayón text
son aprobadas para uso restrictivo en
situaciones de emergencia joe sene
amargant y el instituto serum la empresa
de fabricación de vacunas más grande del
mundo fue contratada por astrazéneca
para hacer millones de dosis el primer
ministro- narendra
indicó que ambas vacunas fueron hechas
en suelo indio le enorgullece ser a cada
indio saber que las dos vacunas que
fueron aprobadas para uso de emergencia
fueron hechas en india el proceso de
inmunización planea vacunar a unos 300
millones de personas a agosto de 2021
entre esos trabajadores de la salud en
primera línea la policía y enfermos
ambas vacunas tienen dos dosis de cuatro
semanas y deben ser almacenadas a menos
2.8 grados celsius pzifer solicitó ser
aprobada también en la nación asiática y
la aplicación se encuentra en estudio
india es el segundo país más afectado
con más casos en el mundo reporta más de
10.3 millones de contagios y unas
150.000 muertes por el patógeno
reino unido reportó 57 mil 725 casos y
445 muertes por ccoo y 19 en las últimas
24 horas siendo este el quinto día
consecutivo en el que son confirmados
más de 50.000 casos en el país
el primer ministro boris johnson aseguró
este domingo que unas 530.000 dosis de
la vacuna desarrollada por astrazéneca y
la universidad de doctor estarán listas
para hacer administradas el lunes y dijo
que espera que decenas de millones de
vacunas más se produzcan en los próximos
tres meses a pesar de la preocupante
situación él también instó a los padres
a seguir mandando a sus menores a los
hijos a las escuelas en las regiones
donde las restricciones lo permitan en
londres permanecerán cerradas
lo que estamos haciendo claramente es
luchar contra la nueva variante del
virus que está surgiendo particularmente
en londres y el sureste de inglaterra y
es por eso que hemos tenido que adoptar
medidas excepcionales y en algunas
partes cerrar las escuelas primarias y
mantenerlas cerradas temporalmente es
craig champéry excusas 6 las escuelas
son seguras es muy importante subrayarlo
la amenaza el riesgo para los niños para
los jóvenes es realmente muy muy pequeño
como lo dicen los científicos el riesgo
para el personal es muy pequeño y es
rarísimo
vamos a mari porque otros dos soldados
franceses perdieron la vida durante un
operativo militar el vehículo en el que
se transportaban fue alcanzado por una
explosión de un artefacto improvisado
otros tres oficiales murieron en
condiciones similares a finales de
diciembre con ellos ya se eleva a 50 el
número de soldados galos fallecidos en
ese país desde que francia inició su
intervención para luchar contra la
insurgencia yihadista en la región del
sahel en 2013 el presidente francés
emmanuel macrón expresó su tristeza por
la noticia
continúen con más siempre las 24 puntos
cuando vemos más adelante
[Música]